Hi, I'm Erik Voss, and we've been hearing
a lot about this Han Solo Star Wars
movie, how director is Phil Lord and
Chris Miller were fired and replaced
with Ron Howard. Now, replacing a director
in the middle of production has
become more of a trend in recent years
with Disney properties, with Han Solo, but
also, rumor has it with Rogue One. Gareth
Edwards reportedly stepped back during
reshoots to allow Tony Gilroy to direct
large parts of the movie. And this has
also happened with Marvel movies, which
are also owned by Disney. With Ant-Man,
initial writer-director, Edgar Wright,
left the project after Marvel head, Kevin
Feige, had a new, less edgy, script
written without Wright's input. Similarly,
Patty Jenkins, before she directed Wonder
Woman for DC, was initially hired to
direct Thor: The Dark World for Disney/Marvel, but then she was fired, too. And
this brings us to the real, deep-rooted
reason why Disney-owned studios, like
Marvel and Lucasfilm, keep clashing with
these directors. I think that when it
comes to the way the studio views its
big film franchises, Disney hates
originality. Now, what do I mean by that?
Or, as you may be thinking, how dare you?
Sure, Disney is the brand of dreams and
imagination, and over the decades it
has often led the way in creative
risk-taking, both in its storytelling and
the way it runs its business, but let's
be honest: Disney is not the studio where
filmmakers go to be original, to buck the
trend, to express their unique voice as
storytellers. Like, it's no secret that
the classic Disney films that we know
and love were really just
family-friendly adaptations of darker
Grimm's Brothers tales. And even though
Pixar, which Disney also owns, has been
known for more innovative, original
stories, that's only because Pixar fought
very hard for that creative independence
from Disney. They actually have a list of
storytelling rules that intentionally
defy the Disney model. Now yes, people
like Kathleen Kennedy at Lucasfilm and
Kevin Feige at Marvel do have
independence in the way they run their
studios, but a lot of their success comes
from the fact that they share Disney's
creative mindset and general risk
aversion. Like, as much as I have loved
Marvel under Feige's direction, a common
complaint is that each movie feels like
the same kind of fun adventure, where
nothing truly dark ever happens. And Edgar Wright trying to go against that with Ant-man...
an insider put it this way - Kevin Feige
and his top lieutenants run Marvel with
a singularity of vision, but when you
take a true auteur and throw him into
the mix, this is what you get. They don't
want you to speak up too much or have
too much vision.
Similarly, the new Disney/Star Wars
movies have been hugely successful, but
some would argue only by sticking close
to the script laid out by the original
trilogy. Like, JJ Abrams was given way
more control over The Force Awakens, but
it was probably really easy for Kennedy
to do that because the movie Abrams wanted to make followed the tone and the
story beats of A New Hope pretty closely.
Meanwhile, whenever these studios try to
partner with directors who are known for
their originality and boldness, their
tendency to resist studio input, even if
it risks alienating parts of the
audience, these days Disney is far more
inclined just to sever ties. Let's look
at Lord and Miller with the Han Solo movie.
So, Lord and Miller are comedy guys. They
directed the Lego Movie and the 21 Jump
Street movies, and a lot of the jokes in
those films come from Lord and Miller
encouraging the actors to improvise and
go off script.
So improv can be a really effective way
to make the comedy in a movie feel
organic and truly as funny as possible.
Directors like Judd Apatow and Adam
McKay use improvisation a lot in their
films. But it sounds like that process did
not gel with the expectations of
Kathleen Kennedy and Lawrence Kasdan, who
wrote the script. Of course, everyone just
chalked it up to creative differences,
which is the explanation everyone uses, but...
here's what I heard.
So sources inside the production claimed
that the crew was annoyed by the slow
process of doing multiple improvised
takes and that the humor was getting a
little too meta. Some people also said
that the acting from Han Solo actor,
Alden Ehrenreich, suffered and that they
had to bring in an acting coach because
his performance was becoming too much
like Ace Ventura. What does that even mean?
Is there a scene were Han was like, fighting
the Sarlacc, and then walks out of the
room and turns to Lando, like, do not go
in there, Woo! I guess it's not very good.
Now another source said that Kathleen
Kennedy just wasn't a fan of the way
that Lord and Miller were doing things
from the beginning, hating the way they
fold socks. Which is a bummer, because have
you seen the way Lord and Miller fold
socks? So fresh and
original! Now, I don't know how many of
these rumors are actually true. For all
we know, they could just be leaks by
insiders at Disney or Lucasfilm to
justify this abrupt firing of directors
in the middle of shooting, which almost
never happens with Hollywood movies. But
here's what I do know: Lawrence Kasdan is
a screenwriting legend who co-wrote The
Empire Strikes Back, Return of the Jedi
and The Force Awakens, so yeah, he's kind
of the authority on the character of Han
Solo, and I honestly wouldn't blame Kasdan if he was frustrated that Lord and
Miller were telling Ehrenreich to ad lib
new Han Solo dialogue to replace the lines
that he wrote in the script.
Han Solo isn't a new, undefined character
that filmmakers can organically develop
on the fly. He's a film icon with a very
specific voice that Kasdan and Disney
are understandably very protective of.
But the frustrating thing about this is
this isn't Lord and Miller's fault.
Lucasfilm and Disney knew exactly what
they were getting when they hired those
two, just like Marvel did when they
initially hired Edgar Wright, the bold
innovator who made Shaun of the Dead, Hot
Fuzz and Scott Pilgrim vs. the World to make
Ant-man. Actually, back when that firing
happened, Joss Whedon said that he read
Edgar Wright's script and said it was
the best script that he had read for the
Marvel Universe to that point. And I've
always felt bummed that we never got to
see that movie. And now I'm kind of
feeling the same way about Lord and
Miller's Han Solo movie. Look, even if
their movie felt tonally off and too
improv-y and meta, with like, Han talking
out of his butt as he solves pet-related
crimes, I still really want to see that
Han Solo! And come on, if Disney is worried
that a weird take on Han Solo would ruin
the Star Wars franchise, obviously that
wouldn't at all be the worst thing to
happen to Star Wars. Unfortunately, we'll
never know what Lord and Miller's movie
will look like because Disney and
Lucasfilm have replaced them with Ron
Howard. Now, Ron Howard is a fine director.
He made Apollo 13, and he won the Oscar
for A Beautiful Mind, he also directed
The Da Vinci Code movies. Yeah, you know,
when Hanks rocked a mullet. Also, it
seems like Star Wars has been near and
dear to Ron Howard's heart for a long
time. In 1999, he wrote a really pissed
off letter to critics, defending Jacob
Lloyd's acting in the Phantom Menace. Of
course, that letter also called Phantom
Menace truly amazing. Umm...
I guess from this point on, if you keep
throwing shade at Alden Ehrenreich's
acting in Han Solo, expect an angry letter
from Ron Howard. I don't really know how
much of a vision Ron Howard has for this
Han Solo movie, or how much of a vision
he really could conceive this late in
the production process.
It sounds like Disney and Lucasfilm
hired him because he's a safe option. Ron
Howard is a veteran director who will
probably honor the vision of Han Solo as
he's laid out in Kasdan's script, and if
you just want a smooth production
process so this Han Solo movie comes
together in one piece, I guess that's
good news. Like, this means we'll get a
more purely Lawrence Kasdan Han Solo
movie now, and that could be perfect. On
the other hand, I feel like Disney's war
against originality has stifled a
potentially new and bold take on Han
Solo. One that could be way better than
the one we end up getting. Remember when
George Lucas made the first Star Wars,
that movie was nothing like any of these
sci-fi fantasy movies that came out in
the seventies. It was a huge risk for the
studio at the time. There were all kinds
of production problems - shooting delays,
going way over budget.
All for this weird, quirky movie about a
space religion and walking carpet. My
point is the original Star Wars worked
because it was original. It became the
biggest movie franchise of all time, and
the concern now is film studios like
Disney have become so successful at
putting out consistent, mass appeal
franchises, all by sticking to a proven
formula, that they now can't stand the
idea of a bold new director allowing his
or her voice to change and evolve those
franchises. And ultimately that could
take some of the joy and excitement out
of the movies, leaving us with our socks
folded by Ron Howard. Do you think it was
fair that Phil Lord and Chris Miller got
fired? Or to look at things a different
way, were Lord and Miller justified in
diverging from Kasdan's script to go
with a more improvisational version of
Han Solo? Like, do you think they could
have damaged the character's reputation?
And do you think Disney plays things too
safe in general? Like, I don't need to
come off anti-Disney at all, but I do
think they would benefit from letting
their directors be more truly original.
Anyway, that's just my take ,but I'm
curious to know what you think. Let me
know down in the comments and hit me up
on twitter (@eavoss) or follow the new
rockstars on twitter (@newrockstars)
and of course like and share this video
and subscribe to new rockstars for all
kinds of videos and opinions about Star
Wars, Marvel, filmmaking in general. And if
you want to be more a part of our team,
have a bigger say in what kind of videos
we make and have access to exclusive
content, you can contribute to us on
patreon, at a monthly rate that you
decide. Big thanks to all of our current
donors, especially Pony Stark. Thanks for
watching, and in the words of my favorite
version of Han Solo that we'll never get
to see, Alrighty then!